район кройцберг у берліні
тут мишка або бо турки в дикі
приходили до нас турецького президента
реджепа тайіпа ердогана фон і радіус
результатам референдуму на свої
підключення
пальця методикою він прийшов дала навіть
ялта раніше не поліп шилася раніше в
Краї не було інфляція у 4060 адже сотки
в париж від 10 гвинтівки з його гада
красиво розум стемп вирішили які skype
зайти категорично проти біля рота не дам
приборкавши свої вкрай
то натисніть на неї владимир та вона з ним
як що tour golf r n думати всі тури
jana моя ж це з диктатурою щось їм slide
повернуть ася туди
зжита в ти умовах заїки вони
проголосувало sediments and kevin штанги
такі команди ризу бури ним результатам
референдуму думі та ціна нафти з моря
страхаємо edge і ним і самим сотень тисяч
турки столітті прийшли манула і одягли на 9
400000 abba 62 адже соткою проголосувала
за суть його розширення сповнена важливість
ердогана ланцюга shiny shoe саміту промови не
безмін їжу конституції Петро 51
спав іванович соток вибір тью німецьке
вугілля дачу пояснює c take papers з травня
шип авторами і вона турки у фарин та кима
і праворуч голосу ердогана Петро малюки
витрати на підлогу його на вибір тип просто на
смугу валимо подругою пак з них
людині пухкої віку
і голосу воловани нас тільки замовлення тут
йти на зради скрипить цю маску про
стан за ходом сама так
маніпулятивно-позиційну акцію
референдум десант турецьких міністрів
печа порахувати інші тури в Європу
німецька шкода стримує на real love
на результати референдуму
заявиш шукаю підвищуючи право турки та брат і
свої консультативно систему та образ
vipzone
якому йому самурая хапай раз кутове
на гарячку вати результати засвітили
собакою розкол турецької істоти тепер
дуже важливо щоб президент ердоган
підтиснув діалог тут своїми опонентами
офіційний діагноз навчання миску німецьких
політиків вже закликати виробляєте
переговорів структурі пдв і заморозити і
фінансову допомогу та кандидатами на
членство і дайте про мільярди євро
віці брюссель виділяє чи наплив
анкери на частку євростандарту багата хтось
перк після референдуму та перу шериф
становище ардагану по суті авторитарних
поважається марна трата you брошів